that's the type he was hitting the other
night when he came back he looks very
very good
nice pass dowdy inside for the jam
Austin Wiley than Rhoda Nathan's been
hit the eye Dunbar couldn't control it
save by Washington
two-on-one Hagen's playing catch
[Applause]
major bleep daddy bar-parlour flips it
up no a touch out of control but what an
effort from behind that didn't get to
the glass by the way so that's a good
block take a look at it big split second
type defense hit with Hagen's show them
a double now it's Harper
that's right Harper acceleration for the
bucket were tied at 62 the final floor
on the line three seconds two seconds
Spencer bonus basketball in Kansas City
better get it involved in a hurry
six to shoot the take-off loads it up
[Applause]
don't go to point guard toe SEC
Defensive Player of the Year the
freshman Hagen's Harper the blow by
sticks it is the traffic he's gonna
climb and go to his right our left
looking at it through 20 seconds left in
overtime Washington fires that's DJ
Washington three American has 28 for
Kentucky seven seconds swings at
Washington fires
[Applause]